how do you make a robot better at
picking fruit
these days when you tuck into a tomato
soup prepare some roast potatoes or take
a sip of wine there's a good chance that
those fruits and vegetables were
harvested by machines it's quicker
cheaper and can mean less food waste
from labor shortages
but some plants are easier for machines
to harvest than others
soft fruits need a delicate touch and
the raspberry has proved a particular
problem for robotic Pickers
so far machines haven't been able to
match up to a human's ability to pluck
the fruit from the stem without crushing
it
but now a team in Switzerland think they
have a solution and it's this a robotic
raspberry
this fake fruit is designed to train
robots to be better raspberry Pickers it
mimics elements of a real raspberry
squishiness the way it clings to the
stem the way the stem itself bends when
you pull on it
this raspberry has a sensor inside it
can measure the exact pressure and
changes in pressure that a human exerts
on it recording the technique of expert
raspberry Pickers
it then Compares that to what a
raspberry picking robot does and feeds
feeds information to the robot on where
it was going wrong
researchers have learned for example
that as humans pull a raspberry from the
stem they immediately soften their grip
to a more gentle hold and they can now
apply this knowledge to the robot
[Music]
lab trained robot proved
accepting the effective when they
eventually tested it on real raspberries
but it's not fully ready for the big
time just yet
still the researchers say that using lab
versions of fruit could save hours of
expensive field tests all sorts of
robots could be trained and developed in
the lab using robotic fruit before being
tested on the real thing
so you could soon be tucking into even
more machine harvested fruit all thanks
to this robotic raspberry
they did it well